[Music]
tens of millions of people believed what
seemed like a feel-good story about a
New Jersey couple helping a homeless man
now prosecutors say it was a huge scam
they claimed mark D'Amico and Caitlin
McClure conspired with Johnny Bobbitt to
defraud people out of more than four
hundred thousand dollars the couple set
up a GoFundMe account for Bobbitt after
McClure said he helped her mega Oliver
is here with why prosecutors say it was
all made up man good morning good
morning the heartwarming story drew
worldwide attention during the holidays
last year but a clash over the GoFundMe
cash also eventually caught the interest
of local prosecutors it was fictitious
and illegal and there are consequences
New Jersey County prosecutors on
Wednesday charged Johnny Bobbitt Katelyn
McClure in Marc D'Amico with decieving
GoFundMe donors out of thousands of
dollars
D'Amico Maclaurin Bobbitt conspired to
pass up a fake feel-good story that
would compel donors to contribute to
their cause and it worked as their story
goes Bobbitt who was homeless gave his
last $20 to buy gas for McClure who was
stranded outside Philadelphia they
allegedly tried to pay back Bob it's act
of kindness through a GoFundMe campaign
more than 14 thousand donors contributed
nearly four hundred three thousand
dollars in a month but the friendship
began unraveling Bobbitt sued the couple
claiming they were withholding the money
the couple accused Bobbitt of using it
for drugs if they hadn't started
fighting over the money would they have
gotten away with this it's a good chance
they might have prosecutors say D'Amico
and McClure bought a BMW and quote hit
the casinos hard with drawing more than
eighty five thousand dollars for trips
to Las Vegas and Atlantic City have you
spent one dollar of that four hundred
thousand on yourselves no nothing you're
representing that right here and right
now they're never gonna be any proof
that you did that you did not
prosecutors say McClure sent a text
message to a friend acknowledging the
story was quote completely made-up
people giving to people is amazing but
these cases sort of highlight the risks
each
Gonzalez runs a website called go fraud
me which tracks fake GoFundMe campaigns
the question is are the donors following
up on these causes and knowing where
their money actually goes investigators
say GoFundMe will reimburse donors who
contributed to this campaign an attorney
from McClure and D'Amico say they have
no comment on the charges Bobbitt's
attorney could not be reached for
comment and the prosecutor told us that
text messages showed they were also
pursuing a book deal but they were
hoping would raise even more money
that's so despicable they put a lot of
work into defrauding a lot of people and
when you heard it yesterday I could I
thought I was hearing it wrong hopefully
just went from bad to worse playing on
people's best intention played it's not
just fraud it's fraud that reaches into
the most sensitive best part of people
and ruins it and they went to greedy
school that's why they got caught yeah
II hadn't tried to turn on each other I
started writing I've never known
despicable greedy screaming that's right
you're absolutely right
yeah thank you my not a fan